في السودان تاجيل التوقيع على الاتفاق
النهائي بسبب عدم التوصل لتوافق حول بعض
القضايا العالقه
واستنقسام امريكي محامود ترامب يؤكدون انه
سيسلم نفسه لكنه لن يقبل باي صفقه للاقرار
بالذنب
روسيا تحتاج على تصرفات القوات الامريكيه
في سوريا وتصفها بالاستفزازيه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
هذه النشره الاخباريه اعلن المتحدث باسم
العمليه السياسيه في السودان خالد عمرو
يوسف عن تاجيل التوقيع على الاتفاق
النهائي بسبب عدم التوصل لتوافق حول بعض
القضايا العالقه واضاف يوسف ان اجتماعا
سيعقد ظهر اليوم السبت في القصر الجمهوري
وسيضم الاطراف المدنيه والعسكريه الموقعه
على الاتفاق الايطالي لتحديد الموعد
الجديد للتوقيع
اعلنا محامي الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب الاتفاق مع المدعي العام في
منهات على ان لا يتم تقييد ايدي ترامب
اثناء مثوله امام المكتب لتوجيه الاتهامات
اليه يوم الثلاثاء المقبل واضاف المحامي
ان ترامب مصدوم من تفاصيل رائحه الاتهام
المواجهه اليه فيما اتهم الرئيس السابق
مدعي عاما هاتا بتاسيس ملفه فور صدور
الاتهام من جهته اكد البيت الابيض انه لن
يعلق على ما يحدث مع ترامب
من المتوقع ان يسلم الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب نفسه للشرطه يوم
الثلاثاء في مدينه نيويورك وسيتم اخذ
بصمات يده وتصويره كما هو معتاد في حالات
الاعتقال مع عدم تقييد يديه لكن ولانه
رئيس سابق من المتوقع ان يدخل من باب سري
لاحتواء الاحتجاجات وتعجيل اجراءات مثوله
اذا امكن في مده تتراوح بين العشر دقائق
الى نصف ساعه محاموت ترامب قالوا انه
سيؤكد انه غير مذنب ومن ثم سيتم اطلاق
سراحه نظرا لان الاتهامات ليست جريمه
عنيفه على ان تتم المحاكمه لاحقا امر قد
يستغرق اشهرا طويله اذا لم يكن سنوات ومن
ثم يعود ترامب الى فلوريدا اما شرطه
نيويورك فاخذت احتياطاتها الامنيه تحسبا
للتظاهرات المؤيده والمعارضه
ما هي هيئه المحلفين الكبرى التي صوتت
لصالح توجيه اتهامات لرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب في منهاتن ما هي
اختصاصاتها وكيف تعمل وما الفرق بينها
وبين هيئه المحلفين الصغرى
هيئه المحلفين الكبرى في الولايات المتحده
تتكون من 16 الى 23 شخصا
من صلاحيتها توجيه الاتهام المباشر في
قضيه من القضايا تجتمع سرا ومداولتها ليست
مفتوحه لا يحق للمتهمين ومحاميهما المثول
امام هيئه المحلفين
الحكم يحتاج الى اغلبيه الاصوات للاجماع
معيار اثبات الدليل مخفف ويكفي الترجيح
لاصدار التهمه
اما هيئه المحلفين الصغرى تضم سته اشخاص
الى 12 شخصا جلساتها علنيه لكن مداولتها
خاصه
يتمتع المتهم بحق المثول امامها للشهاده
واستدعاء الشهود
الحكم يحتاج الى اجماع كل اعضاء هيئه
المحلفين لابد من اثبات الحجه على المتهم
لاصدار الحكم بحقه
[موسيقى]
قضيته الرئيس السابق امام المحاكم
الامريكيه اصبحت الحدث الاهم في الحياه
السياسيه والنقاش بين الامريكيين والحزبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي
انقسمت الولايات المتحده خلال الساعات
الماضيه حول توجيه تهمه للرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب في قضيه دفع اموال للممثله
الاباحيه ستورميدانيا الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن عمل بسرعه على ابعاد نفسه عن هذه
القضيه لا نتكلم عن توجيه التهم الى ترامب
وتاكيدا على عدم الانقراض في القضيه اكدت
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كارين جانبياد
وهي على الطائره الرئاسيه ان بايدن علم
بتصويت هيئه المحلفين من الاعلام
كلنا بمنفينا الرئيس علمنا بالخبر مثل اي
امريكي من التقارير الاخباريه
الجمهوريون بمن فيهم المنافسون للرئيس
السابق مثل نائبه
اعتبروا ان القضيه القانونيه تثير الغضب
انها سابقه توجيه تهمه لرئيس سابق بشان
التمويل الانتخابي امر مثير للغضب
كرر الجمريون خلال الساعات الماضيه الموقف
ذاته فيما اكد حاكم فلوريدا وهو اقرب
المنافسين الرئاسيين لترامب انه لن يتعاون
مع اجهزه الامن في القاء القبض على ترامب
لو كان مطلوبا اما الديمقراطيون فعمل
زعمائهم على تقديم القضيه على انها مساله
عداله ولا احد فوق القانون
انها سابقه ان يتم توقيفه في تهم جنائيه
ولكن لو رات هيئه المحلفين في منهات انه
ارتكب جريمه والمدعي العام هناك يستطيع
اثبات التهمه بدون شكوك فيجب توجيه التهمه
له مثل اي شخص اخر
والان تتجه الانظار الى مبنى المحكمه في
نيويورك حيث من المنتظر ان ياتي دونالد
ترامب الاسبوع المقبل ويستمع الى التهم
الموجهه اليه
الاجراءات الامنيه تساعدت خلال الساعات
الماضيه ولكن لا غضب في الشارع ولا تظاهره
يستطيع ان يصبح رئيسا ولو كان مذنبا يجب
ان تكون جريمه اكبر بكثير ليكون هنالك
مانع من توليه الرئاسه
حفظ الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب على شعبيه
مرتفعه خلال الاشهر الماضيه ووصلت الى
اربعين في المئه من الامريكيين وربما
يحافظ على هذه الشعبيه على رغم الاتهامات
والمحاكمات في العربيه
اضحى الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
اول رئيس في التاريخ يتهموا في قضيه شراء
صمت ممثله اباحيه وهذه ليست القضيه الاولى
التي يتهم فيها ترامب ويتم التحقيق معه
بخصوصها فيما يلي عرض لمشاكله الاخرى مع
القضاء
[موسيقى]
الاتهامات الجنائيه ليست وحدها التي
يواجهها ترامب فالتحقيقات معه متعدده
ومختلفه
الهجوم على الكابيتول لجنه برلمانيه حققت
في دوري ترامب في الهجوم على مبنى
الكونغرس في السادس من يناير 2021
واوسط بان يطلق القضاء الفيدرالي ملاحقه
ضده
انتخابات 2020 في جورجيا مدعيه عامه تحقق
في محاولات التاثير على العمليه
الانتخابيه في هذه الولايه التي فاز فيها
بايدن بفارق ضئيل
ارشيف البيت الابيض احتفظ ترامب بوثائق
مصنفه سريه ومن الممكن اصدار لائحه اتهام
فيدراليه في هذا الاطار
[موسيقى]
قضايا ماليه في نيويورك فرض على منظمه
ترامب في نيويورك دفع غرامه تصل قيمتها
الى مليون و600 الف دولار بتهمه الاحتيال
المالي والضريبي للمجموعه التي تنتظر
محاكمه مدنيه اكبر في الخريف
[موسيقى]
وفي اول تعليق لها عبرت ايفانكا ترامب
ابنه الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
عن امتنانها للاشخاص الذين اعربوا عن
دعمهم وغلقهم بشان توجيه لائحه اتهام
لوالدها من جانبه وصف سهر ترامب لائحه
الاتهام بانها مثيره للقلق وانما تم
الاعلان عنه في لائحه الاتهام امر غير
مسبوق
روندي سانديز المنافس الابرز لترامب في
انتخابات 2024 الرئاسيه وصف توجيها
الاتهامات للرئيس السابق بانه مناف للقيام
الامريكيه وقال انه لن يساعد في اي طلب
لتسليم ترامب بعد توجيه اتهام له ويشارك
في وجهه نظره نائب الرئيس الامريكي السابق
الذي قال ان الاتهامات ستصبح بالنسبه
للشعب الامريكي مثالا اخر على تجريم
السياسه في البلاد
وانتقد اريك نجل دونالد ترامب الادعاء
العام ايضا واصفا القضيه بانها ذات دوافع
سياسيه وقال لابن الثاني لترامب على تويتر
هذا سوء تصرف قضائي ينتمي الى دول العالم
الثالث مضيفا انه استهداف انتهازي لخصم
سياسي في عام الحملات الانتخابيه
اما من جهه اخرى رئيسه مجلس النواب
الامريكي السابقا نانسي بيلوسي شددت على
ان هيئه المحلفين الكبرى تصرفت بناء على
الحقائق والقوانين مؤكده ان لا احد فوق
القرن
[موسيقى]
اعلنا نائب رئيس المركز الروسي للمصالحه
بين الاطراف المتحاربه في سوريا
عن وجود اعمال استفزازيه من جانب القوات
الامريكيه في الحسكه السوريه وقال غورينو
بان الجانب الروسي قدم احتجاجا للتحالف
الدولي بعدما رصد حركه دوريتين تابعتين له
في منطقه خفض التصعيد مشيرا الى ان انتهاك
التحالف الدولي لقواعد عدم الاشتباك يهدد
توازن القوى الهش في المنطقه والذي تحقق
بفضل جهود روسيا
قررت الولايات المتحده تمديد مهمه حامله
طائرات جورج اتش اتش دبليو بوش ومجموعه
السفن المرافقه لها لتوفير خيارات بعدها
هجمات دمويه شنتها قوات مدعومه من ايران
في سوريا الاسبوع الماضي وذلك وفق مسؤولين
في الجيش الامريكي ومن المرجح ان يعني
القرار عدم عوده الحامله والمجموعه
المرافقه التي تضم اكثر من خمسه الاف جندي
امريكي والمتواجد حاليا في منطقه العمليات
التابعه للقياده الاوروبيه الى مينائها
الرئيسي في الولايات المتحده حسب الجدول
المقرر
قال رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه مارك
ميلي ان اوكرانيا لن تكون قادره على تحقيق
اهدافها العسكريه في المستقبل القريب وفي
وقت سابق اكد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
قد تحاول استعاده بعض الاراضي ولكن ليس في
ساحه المعركه بل بطرق اخرى
وقع رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مرسوما
يحدد مفهوم سياسه الخارجيه الجديده لموسكو
تعتبر الولايات المتحده المحركه الرئيسي
والمصدر الاساسي للسياسه المعاديه لروسيا
واكبر تهديدا يواجه العالم وتطور البشريه
ابرز ملامح العقيده الروسيه في التقرير
التالي
في ظل احتدام الخلاف بين المعسكرين الغربي
والشرقي على خلفيه الحرب في اوكرانيا جدد
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين سياسه بلاده
الخارجيه موقعا مرسوما للعقيده الروسيه
الجديده الرئيس الروسي عازا المرسوم
الجديد الى الاضطرابات الحاليه على الساحه
الدوليه والتي تدعو الى تخطيط استراتيجي
جديد ويتضمن مفهوم السياسه الخارجيه
الجديده نقاطا عده منها السماح باستخدام
القوات الروسيه لمنع اي هجوم على روسيا
وحلفائها والاستجابه للتهديدات التي تتعرض
لها كما وصف المرسوم الولايات المتحده
بالمصدر الاساسي للسياسه المعاديه لروسيا
مع عدم وجود اي نوايا روسيه معاديه تجاه
اوروبا
الرئيس الروسي اعلن ضمن المرسوم عن
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه مع الهند والصين رغم
الخلافات العميقه بين البلدين
السياسه الخارجيه الجديده
ركزت على ازاله بقايا الهيمنه الامريكيه
على الساحه الدوليه
لتقيم روسيا نظاما عالميا ينطوي على
مفاهيم الامان وتساوي الفرص
عقيده تبدو اشد من الخط الذي تتبناه موسكو
الا ان مفرزاتها الاوليه ستبدو جريه على
ارض الواقع في اوكرانيا
قال صندوق النقد الدولي ان مجلسه التنفيذي
وافق على خطه مساعدات لاوكرانيا باكثر من
15 مليار دولار في اطار حزمه دعم دوليه
حجمها 115 مليار دولار امريكي وتوقع
الصندوق في بيان ان يساعد القرار على جمع
تمويل ميسور من المانحين والشركاء
الدوليين لاوكرانيا وجاء في البيان ان
الاليه اليه التمويل الموسعه الجديده
ستسمح بصرف مليارين وسبعمائه مليون دولار
على الفور لاوكرانيا
اعلنت المجال ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يقترب
من مناقشه نشر قوه حفظ سلام اوروبيه في
اوكرانيا ليرد بانه طرح خطر ما يعرض
الازمه الاوكرانيه الى المزيد من التصعيد
نيران الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا مشتعله
منذ اكثر من عام ليطرح تساؤل جديد حول
مستقبلها هل تكون القبعات الزرق من يبرد
نيران الحرب ام من يؤججها طرح جديد على
طاوله النقاش الاوروبيه اقترحوا ارسال
قوات حفظ سلام اوروبيه الى اوكرانيا كما
اعلنت المجر نحن قريبون من مناقشه مساله
مقبوله وشرعيه مع القاده الاوروبيين بشان
امكانيه ارسال الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد
الاوروبي قوات حفظ سلام الى اوكرانيا
طرح قد يغير التقسيم الجغرافيه لاوكرانيا
ففي حال انتشار قوات حفظ السلام في
المناطق الفاصله بين سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه قد تصبح السيطره
الروسيه شرعيه امر واقع على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه مع الزمن
وجمعوا ديركيب الارثوذكسي احد اكبر
المراكز المسيحيه في اوكرانيا وهو معلم من
معالم التاريخ والهندسه المعماريه قررت
وزاره الثقافه الاوكرانيه عدم تمديد عقد
الايجار للكنيسه الاوكرانيه الارثوذكسيه
نسبه لارتباطها بكنيسه موسكو والارتباط
قساوستها باجهزه الامن الروسيه الامر الذي
تعتبره كييف مهددا للامن القومي لكن
الكنيسه ترفض القرار وتقاومه المزيد في
التقرير التالي
مجمع ديركي احد اكبر المراكز المسيحيه في
اوكرانيا ويعرف بدير الكهوف الذي اعتبر
معقلا للارثوذكسيه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
حتى بدايه الحرب الروسيه عليها فاعلنت
الكنيسه قطع علاقتها بكنيسه موسكو
واستقلاليتها منها الا ان ذلك لم يشفع لها
فظلت الكنيسه تواجه اتهامات بتبعيتها
لموسكو والترويج للعالم الروسي فقامت
السلطات الاوكرانيه بعده عمليات تفتيش في
المباني الدينيه لهذه الكنيسه والدير
وفرضت عقوبات على رجال الدين بسبب مواقفهم
التي تعتبر مواليه للروسيا
المساله ليست رغبه الدوله في تحديد من
ينتمي الى اي طائفه هذه مساله تتعلق بامن
الدوله لا يمكن ان تكون هناك كنيسه على
اراضينا تقود الى صراع داخلي على وطنه على
ذلك تظهر اجراءات التحقيق التي يتم
تنفيذها بان هذه الكنيسه والافراد
العاملين بها يتعاونون بشكل وثيق مع الخ
الخاصه الروسيه ظلت رئاسه الكنيسه واداره
المحميه موضع انتقاد للصحفيين والجمهور
بسبب القوالب النمطيه المتمركزه حول
الامبراطوريه الروسيه واستخدام اللغه
الروسيه خلال الصلوات كما تقول السلطات
انه تم تنفيذ اعمال بناء واعاده بناء غير
قانونيه للمعالم التاريخيه في ارض المحميه
بالرغم من عدم وجود اي تصاريح بناء وبموجب
ذلك اعلن وزير الثقافه الاوكراني
انهاء عقد الايجار الذي سمح للكنيسه
باستئجار قسم من هذا الدير مجانا بحجه
انتهاكات لقواعد استخدام املاك الدوله
لن نغادر لافا بعد لانه يجب تزويدنا
بالاسباب التي يتم على اساسها طردنا من
هنا ولكن ببساطه القول باننا يجب ان نترك
الافرا امر غير مفهوم لاي شخص الا ان
الكنيسه وعلى لسان رئيس الاساقفه الناطق
باسمها رفضت الادعاءات وقالت ان كنيستنا
كانت الاولى بين كل المنظمات الدينيه في
اوكرانيا التي دالت حرب بوتين ضد اوكرانيا
اشعر بالاسف حياله من سيشاركون في الاخلاق
لان الامر لن ينتهي هنا وهذا سينعكس على
مصير كل شخص سيطرد القساوسه فعليا
الاوكرانيون خائفون خائفون بشده عندما
تدعو الحكومه الى ذلك وعندما تفعل مثل هذا
الشيء ضد شعبها وكان الرئيس الاوكراني
تحدث من جهته عن ضروره الدفاع عن
الاستقلاليه الروحيه في مواجهه موسكو
الامر الذي وجد استحسان بعض مناهضي
الارثوذكسيه الروسيه لقناتها العربيه
والحدث حذيفه عادل كيف
وفي قضيه الصحفي الامريكيه المعتقل في
روسيا طلب الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن من
موسكو الافراج عن مراسل
والذي اوقف في روسيا بتهمه التجسس خاطب
بيضا الحكومه الروسيه قائلا افرجوا عنه
اكد السفير الامريكي لدى تونس جوي هود
استعداد بلاده لمواصله الدعم تونس في
مسارها الاصلاحي خاصه على مستوى المفاوضات
مع صندوق النقد الدولي جاء ذلك خلال لقاء
هود بوزير الاقتصاد والتخطيط التونسي سمير
سعيد ومن جانبه اكد وزير الاقتصاد التونسي
على اهميه دعم الولايات المتحده وشركاء
بلاده للبرنامج الاصلاحيه
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
كبروا محامي تيك توك يؤكد سلامه بيانات
المستخدمين في الولايات المتحده
اهلا بكم من جديد قدرت الامم المتحده ان
الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وسوريا في
فبراير الماضي خلف اضرارا تتجاوز 20% من
اجمالين انتاج الزراعي التركي واوضحت
منظمه الامم المتحده للاغذيه والزراعه ان
الزلزاله تسبب في اضرار جسيمه لانقطاع
الزراعه في تركيا بما في ذلك المحاصيل
والثروه الحيوانيه ومصائد الاسماك فضلا عن
البنيه التحتيه الريفيه في المناطق
المتضرره
عدلت وكاله ستاندرز امبور للتصنيف
الائتماني نظرتها المستقبليه لتركيا من
مستقره الى سلبيه واضافت الوكاله ان
النظره المستقبليه السلبيه تعكس المخاطر
التي تواجهها الجداره الائتمانيه لتركيا
بسبب ما تعتبره عدم امكانيه استدامه
السياسات النقديه والماليه والاقتصاديه
افادت وزاره العدل الامريكيه بانها ستحتفظ
باسلحه تمت مصادرتها في الطرق في الطريق
لليمن من ايران واضافت العدل الامريكيه
انها صادرت اكثر من مليون قطعه من الذخائر
كانت متجهه لليمن وانا البحريه احبطت وصول
الالاف من اجهزه التفجير الصاروخي لليمن
في خطوه امريكيه جديده تهدف للتصدي لتنام
النفوذ الصيني في منطقه المحيطين الهندي
والهادئ اعلنت اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن عزمها على فتح سفاره في دوله بنواتو
وهي الجزيره الواقعه في جنوب المحيط
الهادئ
بالتزامن مع زياره رئيس تايوان الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قالت السلطات
في تايبيه ان تسعه مقاتله صينيه عبرت خط
الوسط في مضيق تايوان لتزيد من حده التوتر
الحاصل بين
التي تعتبر المضيق جزءا لا يتجزا من
اراضيها وترفض التعامل مع تايوان كدوله
تحركات جديده في مضيق تايوان نفذتها تسع
طائرات صينيه مقاتله التي عبرت خط الوسط
في المضيق الذي لطالما كان ساحه حرب غير
مباشره بين بكين وواشنطن التي تطالب
بالسياده الكامله على اراضيها اجراءات
حازمه ومضاده توعدت بها الصين وصفتها
تايوان بغير العقلانيه في اشاره الى ان
بيكين تتعمد اثاره حاله من التوتر وعدم
الاستقرار في المضيق بالتزامن مع الزياره
التي تقوم بها رئيسه تايوان الى الولايات
المتحده والتي اعتبرها مراقبون جرس انذار
لها من القيام باي استفزازات جديده تغضب
بكين غير ان رئيسه تايوان تعهدت بعدم
السماح للضغط الخارجي بمنع الجزيره من
التعامل مع العالم بعد التهديدات الصينيه
مشيره الى ان تايوان مستمره في المضي قدما
نحو تحقيق سيادتها الكامله وحريتها ولا
تعد هذه المره الاولى التي تعبر فيها
طائرات صينيه مقاتله خط الوسط لمضيق
تايوان الذي لا تعترف به بكين حيث تقول ان
كل تحرك للصين داخله يعد مساسا بسيادتها
خط تتقاطع فيه مخاطر الاشتباكات السياسيه
والحوادث العسكريه نظرا لضيقه حيث لا
يتجاوز عرضه 130 كيلومترا في اضيق نقطه
فيها ولطالما شكل هذا الخط عنوان ازمه
متواتره بين تايوان والصين التي تعتبر
الجزيره جزءا من اراضيها وترفض اي علاقات
دوليه رسميه معها
كشف قائد الجيش الهندي ان تعمق القوات
الصينيه في الاراضي الهنديه سيحفز النزاع
الحدودي بين البلدين الجنرال
اكد ان عمليات التوغل هي فتيل تصعيد محتمل
في منطقه لداخ تحديدا كما صرح ان الجيش
الهندي اعاد توزيع قوته لمواجهه الصين على
الحدود
قالت اداره الفضاء الالكترونيه الصينيه
انها ستجري فحصا لمنتجات شركه ميكرون
تكنولوجي الامريكيه المصنعه لرقائق
الذاكره في البلاد تحسبا لوجود مخاطر
امنيه بها واشارت الاداره في بيان ان هذه
الخطوه التي تاتي وسط خلافا حول تكنولوجيا
الرقائق بين واشنطن تستهدف حمايه امن
سلسله التوريد للبنيه التحتيه الحيويه
للمعلومات ومنع المخاطر الخفيه وحمايه
الامن القومي
افاد كبير محامي تيك توك اريك بان اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن لم تقدم اي
تعليقات للشركه منذ ان ادلى رئيسها
التنفيذي بشهادته امام الكونفرس الاسبوع
الماضي واضاف اندرسون ان تيك توك جددت
فرحه اقتراح اقتراحا لتخزين جميع بيانات
المستخدمين الامريكيين على الخوادم التي
تمتلكها وتديرها شركه اوركل العملاقه
للبرمجيات من اجل تهدئه مخاوف المسؤولين
الامريكيين
تتواصلوا التحذيرات من السفر الى دول دول
تفشى فيها مرض فيروس ماربورغ في افريقيا
وهي تنزانيا وغينيا الاستوائيه كون المرض
شديد العدوى وتصل فيه نسبه الوفيات من 60
الى 80%
كيفيه الوقايه من مرض فيروس مارب تاجيل
السفر الى الدول الموبوءه بالمرض الا
للضروره القصوى في حال الحاجه الملحه
للسفر الى الدول الموبوءه يجب تجنب
الاتصال المباشر بالمرضى
او من تظهر عليهم اعراض مثل الحمى والام
العضلات والتفح الجلدي
تجنب ملامسه خفافيش الفاكهه وكذلك تجنب
زياره الكهوف والمناجم التي تعيش فيها
تجنب الاقتراب من الحيوانات مثل الشمبانزي
والغوريلا
[موسيقى]
في الحرم المكي في تصريحا للعربيه ان عدد
صور المسجد الحرام خلال الايام الثمانيه
الاولى من رمضان بلغ اكثر من سبعه ملايين
ومائه وعشرين الفا مشيرا الى ان متوسط مده
السعي والطواف بلغت ساعه وسبع واربعين
دقيقه خلال هذه الفتره
بلغ اجمالي عدد زوار المسجد الحرام خلال
ثمانيه ايام سبعه مليون و420 الف
معتمر وزائر فيما بلغ متوسط لمده السعي
والطواف ساعه وسبعه واربعين دقيقه خلال
هذه الفتره تم توزيع 364 الف
وثمانين عبوه ما زمزم خلال داخل زحم
المطاف كما بلغ عدد المستفيدين من التوعيه
الميدانيه مليون و700 الف المستفيدين من
خدمه الارشاد المكاني باللغات والترجمه
بلغ عدد اللغات 51 لغه وعدد المستفيدين
اكثر من 500 الف مستفيد كما بلغ اجمالي
المطهرات والمعقمات مليون وسبعين الف كما
حرصت الرئاسه على فرش 35 الف داخل بعض
المربعات داخل المسجد الحرام
في اطار ان الدراميا لاحدى قصص السوشيال
ميديا الواقعيه تدور احداث المسلسل
العراقي كاتم والذي يعرض مشاكل واقعيه في
العلاقات الاجتماعيه تبنى على وجود المال
لتحقيق الهدف والمصالح حتى لو كانت على
حساب سلامه الجميع
[موسيقى]
يعني انا احبك مو بايدي شو اسوي يعني بنيه
من طالبه جامعه الى نجمه بالسوشال ميديا
الله اكو واحد ابن امه وابوه يقدر يتجرع
عليه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا في رامي يلقي مسلسل كاتم العراقي
واللي وصف بالجريء جدا الضوء على علاقات
المال والمصالح واللي تتعارض عشان تشكل
احداث خطيره ومثيره ايش معنى هاي القضيه
يريدون يوصلون بيها للحقيقه استاذ جميل
فورا
بالاعلانات تعرفت على الحاج وضعها تحسن من
الاعمال اللي تقدر تقول قصتها مثيره للجدل
يعني تتناول موضوع العصر اللي هو حاليا
البلوجرات
القصه ماخوذه من قصه حقيقيه يعني مقتبس من
عندها مو مو كلها بحذافيرها او من تاليف
الاستاذ احمد هاتف واشتغلنا على المعالجه
الدراميه مع الاستاذ موفق مسعود من سوريا
العمل جريء اليوم مثلا اكو هوايه اشياء
مثلا الناس تشوفها من وجهه نظر
بس اللي وجهه نظر الحقيقيه ما مكشوفه
للعلم قصه عشق تجمع فاشنيستا مع شخصيه
تملك المال
والسلعه بريح فلما الغلبه لشخصيه تبث
الرعب حولها او نفاشنستا تتحكم بالراي
العامريه ترى الدوله ما تحب تسوي مشاكل
ويا ابو لبنى
الظاهره رقم واحد هنا تابع لهم انا شخصيا
سلوان سلوان مصور خريج اكاديميه فنون طموح
يحب يشتغل بس ملاقي الفرصه
جت الفرصه عن طريق بنيه
[موسيقى]
خارج العراق داخل العراق
لا تعرف نهايتها ولا ايش وقت راح تخلص
[موسيقى]